(rock music)
- I don't wanna give it
away, it was the butler.
The butler did it.
- Leave my books alone, okay?
Just let me read.
- Timber.
(rock music)
- What brings you across the pond?
- It's my honeymoon.
- Where's your husband?
- Dead.
(Nick snoring)
- Asleep!
He's dead, dead asleep.
(both laughing)
- Sir, if you don't return to your seat,
I'm gonna have to call--
- The cops.
- Hey, hi honey.
We've actually been married for 15 years,
but we've just been very,
very, very, very busy.
(Nick brushing teeth)
- I'm flossing.
- I can see that.
You're doin' it extra hard tonight.
(rock music)
- Charles is inviting us to
spend the weekend with him
on a yacht.
- Crashing the party with civilians.
- You're an actress, right?
- Grace Ballard.
- (laughing) I an Nick Spitz!
This is my wife, Allison!
I can't believe--
- Audrey.
I'm Audrey.
- I said Audrey!
Did ya ever fool around on a boat?
I just lay here and the
boat does all the work.
(Audrey gasping)
(women screaming)
- [Man] There's been a murder!
- Should we pull it out?
- No, it's a foot long knife.
(knife gets pulled out of body)
(crowd screaming)
- Will you listen to my husband?
He's a detective!
- I'll put it back.
- Don't put it back.
- No!
(Audrey screams)
(police sirens sounding)
- My name is Inspector
Laurent de la Croix,
and we now summon you for questioning.
(puffs smoke out)
- Why is that smoke ring so good?
How did he do that?
- Did you notice anything
out of the ordinary?
- [All] The Americans.
- But we didn't do this.
- [Nick] Someone's trying to frame us.
- We do things together, so can we please
just figure this out?
(gun fires)
(Audrey screams)
- [Audrey] It's just like
"Death in the Library".
- [Nick] What happens in
"Death in the Library"?
- They died.
That's why it's called
"Death in the Library".
(gun fires)
(Audrey screams)
("Look What You Made Me
Do", by Taylor Swift)
♪ Look what you made me do ♪
- You guys are all over the news.
They say you killed someone.
- Do you think that's possible?
- We're trying.
(gun fires four times)
- Shoot at him!
- Those were warning shots, honey!
♪ But I got smarter ♪
- If we're gonna do this,
we gotta look confident.
♪ And me I rise up from the
dead, I do it all the time. ♪
- Boom.
- [Audrey] Go, go, go!
(gun fires)
(police car crashes through plane)
- Ferrari!
- What?
- Testarossa!
Magnum, P.I., I've got the mustache!
- Okay, go!
- It's a fantasy!
(doors slam shut)
What the?
Are you kidding me?
- I'm so sorry,
I don't know what to say!
- Ah, go, go!
(engine revs)
♪ Ooh, look what you made me do ♪
- You have any idea how gorgeous you look?
(Audrey screaming)
- Hit the brakes!
(police car crashes)
- I love you, that was sweet.
♪ Look what you just made me do ♪